okay yeah hello and welcome to this
video with that joy probably took three
see Queens gambit one yep Queens gambit
recently I came across a book that
actually recommends III in this position
I can try them in as we're all ways of
thinking and then they claim that white
can play for an advantage okay here your
white can do that but on takes d4 I
don't really see why it's getting much
this is something we're pleased I feel
white can can hope at least ought to be
63 blitzing out those moves and it's not
really it's not a theoretical position
yet all might be six Bishop before some
nothing particularly well known so what
you're saying is that i cannot sacrifice
on h7 okay
yeah maybe this is the case that I
cannot do it but okay I can I have other
things that look rather dangerous so
let's get this going we should be seven
I might have to check this point but
well that's what it is not before is the
fraction in size Wow
that wouldn't even have made it vaguely
on the list of candidates but maybe it's
a move ok I can take on these hives now
[Music]
it doesn't look like it next that much i
also have d hype and then that's nice to
be formed there should be three is the
most interesting or skype you should f5
now ok let's go for the simple method i
have it he's getting away with this now
he's got Bishop f5 something that I have
not I didn't see her for one night
before you
[Music]
yeah this is what I've what I meant with
getting away with it absolutely nothing
I have and they should have something
because that opening play was pretty bad
I'm fairly certain okay I mean 94 to f6
and his King position is a little bit
more weekend than mine I know it looks
almost m symmetrical but my night is my
night is better positioned there for 94
stuff
yeah this is good for right now it's a
double attack so 94 i also have rupee
eight and clean f8 this is that good
check check check it is good check black
resign okay so so I'm not happy with
this because I think I should punish
this opening play this is already not
not good really you're going back to be
six and combining it with Bishop before
this is weird because you completely
neglect your King side you would have to
put it back on the seven very very
likely and taking 1c3 also is no not a
good idea here because the pieces are
wrong for playing against those pawns
okay I plate this rookie eight yeah and
this does not yet work probably check
here you have to go to g8 this is
probably probably good for white this is
a normal way not so what the engine is
giving this is some yeah an issue
relation for black but two should be sex
okay the computer doesn't see a win but
this is not the real thing thinking GA
it was what I saw that and I didn't see
a win here I can't check and play this
but it doesn't look like something
special okay so Queen these ages six
maybe h4 is wrong we should h6 certainly
makes sense yeah this is a smooth as
possible I mean it looks like it looks
weird to me
but it might be okay computer doesn't
find anything yeah he f6 was a bit of a
gamble i was thinking okay I should have
something with Bishop b3 but maybe
that's not the case computer doesn't
shatter the degree yeah just come yeah
so f6 was critical when I have to go to
e3 then TM I didn't find anything better
than this this is nothing position which
is really entirely equal but he played
some really weird move why whoopty 6 why
do you go into this fork basically and
neglect the back rank that's a really
strange move and I don't see the point
of it where the look is going I doesn't
seem to be an immediate problem but this
is am queen a3 and it basically gives
away the Pawnee has to play Queen 26 now
and then i will point up yeah this was
yeah yeah okay just blundering the house
yet I didn't really exploit this open
language I think I should have done
somehow like here broke into the
computer is not giving me all that much
I mean something like this is is
probably comfortable but nothing special
and it gimme five ha somehow if I've
keeps popping up
maybe I have to do this first this could
be interesting actually because he has
to go to e7 did this I can sacrifice
yeah for sure kam ok + + 2 y this I can
do the pony the bishop is obstructing
and this is clearly not working so he
has to go to e7 yeah so this is probably
right here first do this making go back
to e7 and then continue and now whatever
Bishop h six or so yeah this looks good
that this looks good I mean this is not
like winning all or something like that
but it sir this is a better than average
IQ p position you just still wants to
play you fight it crazy I'm glad when I
should do this to stop you five yeah it
looks a bit better for what ok guys
thanks for watching